so I saw something the other day that
said
poor people use debit cards rich people
use credit cards I don't have any credit
cards should I so here's the thing
people get credit cards for mainly one
reason
so they can buy crap they don't have the
money to buy
right and then they justify it going
well I need to build my credit
that's what they say because that's what
rich people do rich people build their
credit bull crap all the rich people
that we interview say they get out of
debt and stay out of debt
and that's how they got rich they don't
pay payments all the time because see
there's only one way to build your
credit go in debt right
right why so you can build your credit
why so I can go into debt why so I can
build my credit why so I can go into
debt why so I can build my credit it's a
dog chasing its tail it's called the
Great FICO scam